parkinson's disease it slows the body
and really only gets worse over time now
most patients also have a symptom called
freezing of gait where a person just can
no longer walk but as john langler
explains some new technology is helping
trick minds into walking again part of
living with parkinson's can in time mean
losing independence in particular the
ability to walk a possible solution
could help patients remain mobile when
the body refuses walter dixon was
diagnosed with parkinson's disease in
2019 my problem is is freezing and
movement and trouble getting started you
know i can i get once i get going i'm
good to go sometimes and then if you if
you the old adage about can't walk chew
gum if i start chewing a stick of gum i
may stop you know really literally it's
called freezing of the gate and it's
defined as a sudden onset of immobility
the place i freeze constantly as
doorways and uh it's very embarrassing
to me to be to be that obvious in public
you know i don't like it at all the
reason that it happens is because of a
specific neural pathway in the brain
that gets damaged or disconnected that
makes it so that when your brain is
sending that signal to initiate movement
that signal just doesn't get to the
motor neuron
that are activating your muscles sidney
collins started to oro devices she
wanted to create a device which uses the
same visual and audio cues as physical
therapists it gives me something to look
at so to speak
triggers my brain to look down to laser
and try and put my foot through it or
kick it
like that step into it yeah
give me something to step towards and
then in addition what that does helps to
trigger my thinking towards you know i
listen that i think to myself step
step
step
look at the laser step step and away i
go
it's encouraging for colin i had read
about the impact i knew logically that
these visual and auditory cues worked
but seeing it happen was a whole
different thing
and life-changing for dickson to help
steady me it helps me to walk give me
the courage to do a lot of things i
wouldn't be doing now technology making
a difference one step at a time john
langler live local now